most honored walk is long long gene
watches have won 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece launching the world's most
honored watch is made and guaranteed by
the lone gene with no watch company it's
time for the launching promise Co a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore watch company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the Long
gene Cronus cope mr. William Bradford
Huie editor of the american mercury and
mr. Elliott Haines an editor of United
Nations World our distinguished guests
for this evening is His Excellency dr.
Elise Astro amy-jo in the Indonesian
ambassador to the United States the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers mr. ambassador I'm sure
that our audience is very had to see you
when I show tonight because you
represent the newest nation in the world
a very large and rich nation now sir
will you tell us just something about
the Republic of Indonesia give us a
brief to your graphic description of
your nation well thank you for the words
of welcome Indonesia as you know is a
new country and it's yolk Africa
location is I might say so Freddy
it's an albacore and it's an island
nation relation and it is situated and
South to a specific and this is located
on the cross crossroad of two very
important highways a one from the
mainland of Asia leading to Australia
and the other one is from the north
leading from China from Japan to the to
the south and it's an Alan King and
there are many Alan's right there many
islands we have a process proximately
3,000 islands over day it's an extremely
rich culture in terms of Natural
Resources yes it is I think it ranks
desert behind the United States and
Russia and how many people do you have
sir we have approximately 78 million how
many of those are literate mr.
ambassador
about 20 percent 20 percent can read yes
and they're mainly Muslims aren't they
well yes most of them about 85% are
Muslims and do you have any questions
there we have and that the the
government in government we have cabinet
ministers who are Christian and of
course you were formerly a colony of the
Dutch foreign world yes you were
developed industrially what in what
industrial development you have was
largely the work of the Dutch wasn't it
yes but there wasn't much industrial
development under the Dutch was there no
they were not but most of the industry
as most mostly agricultural industry
sugar you know and tea and coffee were
you in a very strong position
economically when the Dutch left no I
should say not well why was that well
this is I think because of work
conditions and in you renew you attained
your independence from the Dutch
immediately after the Second World War
didn't you not immediately we proclaimed
our independence is 1945 and it was
finally granted the two or three years
ago
in 1949 actually we concluded the
so-called from Table Conference in The
Hague and you are now a completely free
and in the meow nation of 80 million
people it is very rich Alan yes now sir
tonight our people are particularly
interested in the relations between our
two governments we Americans are
wondering who are our friends and who
aren't now is your nation friendly to
America now and to Americans yes we have
the most friendly relations with your
government mr. Wrather governor Dooley
after his return from Indonesia on a
recent trip stated that the Indonesians
by and large did not want to have too
much to do with Westerners including
Americans I think that is not correct
you don't believe that's true I don't
believe that is true now where do you
stand in our great struggle with the
Soviet Union today are you on our on the
side of the West or are you on the side
of the aggression power complex via we
are not aligning ourselves with the
either of the of the controversial camps
you are you are a member you are is it
fair to call you neutralist in any way
struggle between the west and east let
me put it this way we have formulated
our foreign policy as an independent
foreign policy but it does not mean that
we are we have a neutral policy we claim
that our foreign policy is an
independent one but it is an active
independent most of our listeners are
familiar with the positions taken by
narrow of India now would you say that
your your position of your nation as
between the struggle between Russia and
America is Europe is the position of
your nation approximately that position
taken by material here is approximately
similar to dead what would the position
huge country be mr. ambassador if China
should move aggressively South saying
Malaya
you mean red channet red John yes or
that is difficult to say no and of
course we are aware of the changes
eventually changes of that kind as your
government recognized the reality is we
have Rihan and I've also pressed for
admission of Red China into the United
Nations that's right yes what do you
what is your position there why do you
press for that our position is that the
Indonesia believes that the red China
which we recognize as should participate
in the normal way of international
intercourse do you think the United
Nations you think that if they did
participate in that manner that the Cold
War would ease off at all yes we believe
that you do believe that mr. ambassador
recently mr. bullet former ambassador to
the Soviet Union told our audience that
today in India he doesn't believe that
either American Capital or American
technicians are welcome
now his American capital welcomed in
Indonesia today well I did I do not know
very much about India but as far as
Indonesia is concerned I would like to
answer that do you think that the
American capitalists the American with
some savings can invested in Indonesia
with complete safety today yes I think
so
is there very much investment going on
from America into Indonesia not yet very
much recently the cabinet of Indonesia
fell and was replaced by a new one
because now what is sunny pardon not yet
to be pleased hope didn't know not
hasn't been replaced yet but it fell
because the that cabinet seemed to be
about to sign an agreement with the
American government to administer some
technical assistance and so forth would
you say that that was a move away from
cooperation with the United States I
don't believe that this is the right
position that way because we have a
thing to wait until a new cabinet has
been formed well but immediately after
that during the sixth session of the
General Assembly in Paris it seemed to
many observers as if Indonesia
has been more negative in regard to
America than it had been before that
well Colonel tickly I think that is not
quite correct in stating that because
the cabinet felt after the session in
Paris now mr. ambassador wanted the
consequence of that is not the result of
this while the two were late I thought I
don't think you don't listen one of the
things that our audience is always
interested about from our friends and
foreign nations is what do you want from
us now are you borrowing money from the
United States now well we have got a
hundred million dollars loan from the
export-import bank to help pulsing up
our economy you borrowed a hundred
million dollars now from the
export-import bank and that's to bolster
your economy is to bolster your currency
I assume of course that is in connection
with our economy currency is not to
peace is to be separated from the
economy that is icing a part of it and
of course you are a great rich country
yourself yes now what can we Americans
expect in return from Indonesia for for
our loans that have already been made
and perhaps additional loans well I
think that your interest in Indonesia is
to see that in Indonesia as an
independent free country and should be
capital strong enough to manage its own
affairs as a sovereign country I see
well now are you a possible ally of ours
and any difficulties that we might have
in the future
well I stated before the 340 friendly
terms with you I was not in the military
or annoying sense no what if I could
switch the topic per minute and ask you
about Japan apparently Japan needs
markets and can learn to read China for
them do you think that Japan could keep
her economy going in with trade in
Southeast Asia well I think for a great
deal Japan has always been
feeling with Indonesia as far as
Indonesia is concerned when if we will
keep its economy going by trade with
Indonesia and other stuff without -
without mainland China well I don't know
but I think it has been an historical
fact that Europe is already 6 ever mr.
ambassador is a class here intercourse
which has as a final question sir we in
America many of our young people are
interested in nations where there's hope
whether its development we were once a
young country ourselves now is Indonesia
a hopeful nation today for young man for
your young man and the other young men
of the world well I think Indonesia it
is a young country I say and when it's
be a young man well thank you very much
for being with us tonight sir they're
kind of you to be with us the editorial
board for this edition of the launching
Cronus cope was mr. Elliott Haines and
mr. William Bradford Huie
our distinguished guest was his
Excellency dr. Allis Astro I'm a yoke
joyeux Indonesian ambassador to the
United States